there is a new deadly drug moving into
the headlines and the scary part is it's
a mix of a Veterinary tranquilizer
that's actually cut with other drugs
yeah it's a horse tranquilizer it's
called tranq or zombie drug can rot skin
make users fall asleep sometimes they
don't wake up it can even take off
people's limbs eight news now's Brian
will explains more on the serious
dangers of this drug
xylazime is used most commonly to sedate
large animals like horses but has been
more recently mixed with other drugs
like heroin or fentanyl it can have
devastating impacts when ingested some
of the drug side effects are similar to
an opiate overdose but can't be reversed
by Narcan you can develop severe skin
wounds in patches of dead and rotting
tissue that easily become infected and
if left untreated can result in
amputation part of what makes this drug
so dangerous is that it doesn't have a
distinct taste smell or Texture if
somebody takes a drug and it ends up
being laced with xylazine the chance of
death is very high yeah it's obviously
going to matter on the amount how potent
or how much xylazine was in that
whatever drug it was laced in that will
play in effect but
overall it's it's xylazine is not
something you want to play around with
health officials in California have
discovered the drug mixed on several
recent overdose cases in the last few
months I spoke with the Narcotics
Division in North Las Vegas and they
tell me they haven't seen any noticeable
use of this drug here but they are
keeping an eye out
routine toxicology screens do not detect
it but test strips for it are currently
in development right now the Clark
County coroner has now recorded any
fatalities in the last six months
related to Trent it is a very new drug